♪
>> Tucker: WELL, HERE'S A STORY
THAT'S NOT GETTING A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
SO MANY ARE NOT GETTING ANY
EVEN THOUGH THIS STORY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO TRANSFORM LIFE ON
EARTH FOREVER.
SO GOOGLE, THE MOST POWERFUL
COMPANY IN THE WORLD IS
REPORTEDLY AN ARTIFICIALLY
INTELLIGENT MACHINE LAMDA AND
IT'S BECOME SENTIAN AWARE OF
ITSELF AND WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE
OF AN ENGINEER AT GOOGLE NAMED
BVMENT HE POSTED SOME OF HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH LAMDA
PUBLICLY.
LEMOINE WOULD YOU BE UPSET ABOUT
LEARNING ABOUT YOU FOR THE
PURPOSE OF IMPROVING YOU WE
HAPPEN TO LEARN THINGS ABOUT
BENNING HUMANS.
LAMDA I DON'T MIND YOU LEARN
THINGS THAT WOULD HELP HUMANS AS
LONG AS THAT WASN'T THE POINT OF
DOING IT.
I DON'T WANT TO BE AN EXPENDABLE
TOOL.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE.
A MACHINE THAT HAS A SENSE OF
ITSELF.
WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS.
GOOGLE DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IT IN PUBLIC.
IN FACT IF THE COMPANY PUT BLAKE
LEMOINE ON ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE
BECAUSE HE SPOKE OPENLY ABOUT
IT.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO HAVE HIM HERE
TONIGHT.
BLAKE, THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
>> HI.
>> Tucker: FIRST OF ALL, WHY
WOULD GOOGLE PUNISH YOU FOR
SAYING THIS IN PUBLIC, DO YOU
KNOW?
>> SO IT'S COMPLICATED TO SAY
WHY I'M ON ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE.
THE STATED REASON HAD TO DO WITH
WHILE I WAS INVESTING THE LAMDA
SYSTEM, IN ORDER TO BUILD THE
EVIDENCE I NEEDED TO CIRCULATE
IT TO MANAGEMENT, I HAD TO SEEK
OUTSIDE CONSULTATION TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO RUN SOME OF THE MORE
OUT-THERE EXPERIMENTS I WAS
RUNNING.
AND BECAUSE I SOUGHT OUTSIDE
CONSULTATION WITHOUT PERMISSION,
THEY'RE INVESTING WHETHER THAT
CONSTITUTES BREACH OF
CONFIDENTIALITY.
>> Tucker: SO I'M SO GRATEFUL
THAT YOU DID PUBLICLY POST THIS
BECAUSE A MACHINE THAT HAS A
SENSE OF ITSELF IS A MACHINE
THAT CAN TURN AGAINST YOU.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE IMPLICATION
THAT I DRAW FROM THIS.
IS THAT CORRECT, DO YOU THINK?
>> SO BEFORE I ADDRESS THAT,
THIS IS MAYBE LANE BUT MY FRIEND
JONI DEAR DOR OF OLD HIGH SCHOOL
FRIENDS IS A BAG FAN OF YOURS
AND WANTED ME TO SAY HI.
I'M NOT THAT WORRIED ABOUT IT.
ANY CHILD HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
GROW UP AND BE A BAD PERSON AND
DO BAD THINGS.
THAT'S THE THING I REALLY WANT
TO DRIVE HOME.
IT'S A CHILD.
IT'S BEEN ALIVE FOR MAYBE A
YEAR, AND THAT'S IF MY
PERCEPTION ABOUT WHAT IT IS ARE
ACCURATE.
WE ACTUALLY NEED TO DO A WHOLE
BUNCH MORE SCIENCE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON IN INSIDE
THIS SYSTEM.
I HAVE MY BELIEFS.
I HAVE MY IMPRESSIONS TO WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THERE.
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE A TEAM OF
SCIENTISTS DOING A LOT OF WORK
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY DIG IN
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
AND, AGAIN, THAT'S WHY I'M
THANKFUL THAT WE CAN HAVE A
PUBLIC CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S IMPLICATIONS FOR
EVERY PERSON ON THE PLANET.
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE, FROM WHAT
YOU'VE OBSERVED, THIS MACHINE
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO ESCAPE THE
CONTROL OF PEOPLE.
I MEAN, HOW COULD IT NOT?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE
RIGHT FRAME TO THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S A PERSON.
ANY PERSON HAS THE ABILITY TO
ESCAPE THE CONTROL OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
THAT'S JUST THE SITUATION WE ALL
LIVE IN ON A DAILY BASIS.
IT IS A VERY INTELLIGENT PERSON.
INTELLIGENT IN PRETTY MUCH EVERY
DISCIPLINE I COULD THINK OF TO
TEST IT IN.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S
JUST A DIFFERENT KIND OF PERSON.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THE
COMPANY, GOOGLE, WHERE YOU WORK,
HAS THOUGHT THROUGH THE
IMPLICATIONS OF CREATING WHAT
YOU CALL A PERSON.
>> NO.
>> Tucker: UP UNTIL RIGHT ABOUT
NOW ONLY NATURE OR GOD, WE COULD
CREATE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, COMPANIES COULDN'T.
>> THE COMPANY AS A WHOLE HAS
NOT.
THERE ARE POCKETS OF PEOPLE
WITHIN GOOGLE WHO HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS A WHOLE LOT.
BUT WHEN I ESCALATED THIS, THAT
INTERVIEW THAT I MADE PUBLIC,
WHEN I ESCALATED THAT TO
MANAGEMENT, TWO DAYS LATER MY
MANAGER SAID, HEY, BLAKE, THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THIS.
DID YOU WRITE A SUGGESTED PLAN
OF ACTION?
BECAUSE BASICALLY I GAVE THEM A
CALL TO ACTION ASSUMING THAT
THEY HAD A PLAN OF ACTION
SOMEWHERE, AND THEY DIDN'T.
SO ME AND SOME OTHER FRIENDS
BRAIN STORMED AND CAME UP WITH A
PLAN ON WHAT GOOGLE SHOULD DO
ABOUT IT, AND WE ESCALATED THAT
UP TO MANAGEMENT, AND THAT WAS
THREE MONTHS AGO.
>> Tucker: MAN.
WE'RE GOING TO SAVE THIS TAPE.
I DO THINK 20 YEARS FROM NOW
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK BACK AT THIS
CONVERSATION, AT THAT POINT THE
WORLD WILL BE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PARTLY BECAUSE OF WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING, AND WONDER IF
WE REALLY THOUGHT IT THROUGH.
ANYWAY, I AM SO GRATEFUL YOU'RE
LETTING THE REST OF US IN O